c'est une nouvelle agression de
professeurs qui est survenu dans la
journée de vendredi la vidéo d'une
vingtaine de secondes tournent en boucle
sur les réseaux sociaux cette
enseignante bousculait donc violente est
en pleine classe celle d'une enseignants
d'un lycée professionnel à
combs-la-ville en seine-et-marne
ils ont tous vu la vidéo les élèves du
lycée jacques prévert réalise peu à peu
la gravité de l'agression qui a eu lieu
vendredi au sein même de leur
établissement sur les images diffusées
sur les réseaux sociaux on peut
apercevoir un élève qui tentent de
quitter la classe avant de projeter
violemment son enseignante au sol
vidéo qui a provoqué une nouvelle vague
d'indignation et urbains qui sont
l'autorité de l'éducation nationale dans
les quartiers sensibles moi quand je
vais tomber la prof c'est la république
que j'ai vu tomber c'est nos valeurs
c'est l'école l'académie de créteil a
tenu à condamner fermement cet acte et a
confirmé son intention de porter plainte
contre le lycéen alors agression en
pleine place les professeurs sont ils en
grand danger
c'est vrai que cette vidéo a fait froid
dans le dos un c'est vrai qu'elle nous
fait tellement de peine pour la pole man
leurs professeurs alors on va revoir
cette vidéo qui a fait tristement le
buzz s'est passé donc vendredi dernier
au lycée professionnel jacques prévert à
combs la ville et c'est vrai que cette
vidéo elle est inadmissible on a avec
nous ce soir merci sarra el aissi merci
d'être avec nous secrétaire d'état
chargée de la jeunesse et de
l'engagement c'est important pour nous
vous soyez là ce soir vous avez répondu
vraiment favorablement à notre
invitation c'est merci à vous parce que
c'est courageux parce que c'est vrai
qu'à l'écran il ya des professeures
et des professeurs qui sont en grand
danger aujourd'hui notamment kevin
bossuet professeur d'histoire jour en
seine-saint-denis merci d'être là qu'est
venu merci
et c'est vrai que vous faites vous avez
fait un tweet notamment ce matin qui a
fait énormément réagir on va le voir
mais regardez
cette vidéo qui nous a vraiment tous
choqués
voilà vous les actions là sur le plateau
c'est vrai que c'est incroyable les
profs sont ils en danger
jorick on a une écoute d'abord kevin
vous êtes prof d'histoire jours en seine
saint denis où sont tes menaces et vous
non je ne me sens pas menacé je suis
très content d'aller dans ma salle de
classe g des élèves formidable mais
c'est vrai que depuis plusieurs années
on sent bien une forme si vous voulez de
menaces à une forme de menace par
rapport à l'essence même de notre métier
quand on doit enseigner les valeurs de
la république on doit enseigner la
laïcité c'est vrai que c'est de plus en
plus compliqué parce que notre discours
est sans arrêt galvaudé notre discours
est sans arrêt remise en question et
puis deux en outre pour revenir sur
cette agression c'est vrai qu'on a
affaire à des adolescents qu'ils sont de
plus en plus violents et que nous
professeurs hussards noirs de la
république en effet on nous demande de
régler l'ensemble des problèmes sociaux
qu'il y a en dehors de l'école et c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu compliqué
alors il faut se rassurer tous les
élèves ne sont pas violents la majorité
des élèves ce sont des gamins qui sont
formidables mais malheureusement ça
parait il ya quelques élèves qui posent
problème et j'entends souvent la gauche
parler du droit à l'éducation pour tous
mais quand vous avez dans une salle de
classe un élève qui perturbent les cours
en fait le droit à l'éducation pour tous
se transforme en droit à l'éducation
pour personne et c'est cela qu'il faut
changer parce qu'on n'en peut plus et
les élèves qui veulent travailler les
élèves de vos banlieues qui veulent s'en
sortir veulent un climat scolaire
efficient pour pouvoir s'en sortir et
pour pouvoir répondre à ce qui est
l'essence même de la république
l'ascension sociale alors on va voir on
va écouter le témoignage d'aminata qui a
assisté à la scène et vous de voir ce
qu'elle dit est assez incroyable raconte
que tous les élèves rigaud regarde
vers la porte j'ai vu que ça parlait de
charger et tous et que la preuve était
tombé et je remercie j'ai vu que tout le
monde rigolait et le projet crée
beaucoup et j'ai dit tantôt 10,1 je
pensais que ces temps je
me disais que j'ai vu que c'était grave
alors oui c'est terrible parce que elle
même elle rigole à moitié en racontant
la scène et moi j'ai vu l'interview je
croise et du maire de la ville
méridionale m c'est un élève dissipé
énoncé par année les dissiper c'est un
élève dissipé c'est un autre qui filme
la scène et qui en plus la poste sur les
réseaux et toute une classe 10 marais
qui se fait rien donc moi c'est pas un
élève qu'il faut sanctionner ces au
moins plusieurs élèves voire toute la
classe
bien sûr que non et même à la personne
qui a filmé heureusement qu'elle a filmé
que l'on voit un peu leurs espaces dans
lesquels
ou
jamais pour des populations
mais c'est loin d'un pari qu'ont dénoncé
pas du tout mais si mais si autrement
dans pâle réplique très important que
l'on voit ce qui peut arriver c'est
scandaleux
filmique merci bien sûr qu'on a on à
sarah à lire al hariri qui est avec le
secrétaire d'état chargé de la jeunesse
et de l'engagement quand vous voyez ça
c'est inadmissible demain c'est
inadmissible de et c'est pas justifiable
3 c'est grave et en fait ce qui est
grave c'est que ce garçon déjà y est
hyper violent fait tomber la preuve
c'est une chose il ne respecte pas son
autorité parce que ludique s'asseoir il
n'a pas l'air de franchement de l'écouté
et 2 celui qui filme c'est grave oui en
fait c'est grave parce qu'on est
interdite dans les collèges dans les
lycées les téléphones portables pour
éviter ça et en plus il fait pas que
filmer il filme et publie et publiant
vraiment en mode diffusion c'est un truc
qui se passe regardez ce qu'ils se faire
baiser hyper grave c'est pour ça que
bernard heureusement qu'il a filmé son
tapis tout leur portée alors vous dites
quoi madame vous savez très bien qu'il
ya des gros problèmes que les profs
souffre
mais cinq exemplaires et tromper vous
que les quelques traits des situations
de violence oui on a et sa montée dans
notre société a de plus en plus de
violence excuse moi excusez moi ça
pouvait enlever votre bancaire de votre
micro elle cogne merci moi
[Applaudissements]
voilà de la violence et y en a de plus
en plus sauf qu'aujourd'hui ça arrive
dans un endroit où il faut pas et donc
gravité de la gravité du moment c'est
que vous condamnez les deux mois je
notation le rectorat je condamne et un
dépôt de plainte qui est fait contre le
jeune qui a eu cet acte qu est-ce qui
restera ce qui reste un jeune m'a
franchement ils risquent pas mal non non
pas du risque je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que dans la loi duch c'est une
nouvelle loi elle date du 24 août fawi
d'aujourd'hui les profs s'alarme de
cette année les profs ils sont
considérés comme détenteur de l'autorité
publique donc quand tu quand et violent
avec un policier on sait que c'est
aggrave sa condamnation s'aggrave sa
peine et donc il va y avoir des
sanctions maintenant c'est d'abord le
conseil disciplinaire qui va être qui va
être saisie il a été exclu immédiatement
de manière conservatoire c'est parents
vont être convoquées il peut être exclu
définitivement de l'établissement mais
faut pas faux pas refiler la difficulté
d'un établissement à l'autre c'est ça ce
qui est assez nouveau et puis pour
revenir quand même sur le deuxième sujet
celui qui filme c'est grave aussi et
donc on a vu ce que ça a mené fin on
n'est pas sur une semaine partout n'est
pas sur une semaine anodine on est
presque un an malheureusement du drame
de samuel pas exact mais ça c'est de la
vidéo et ça c'est grave et ce qui se
passe ce qu'on fait avec un téléphone
sur les réseaux sociaux ça a des
conséquences dans la vraie vie donc un
moment en fait faut leur dire faites
quand tu fais ça c'est grave tu respecte
ni la prof ni ce qui se passe dans la
classe et on respecte même pas les
règles de la créolie mais c'est jeune
homme était un récidiviste c'est pas la
première fois qu'il fait ça il fallait
déjà l'exclure avant alors à la limite
alors que qu'est ce qu'on fait là son
fait raison d'orages sur les noms mais
je suis d'accord et moi sur les quelques
uns quand quelqu'un est perturbateur moi
je rejoins l'enseignant qui dit y a un
moment faut le cadrer le monde et donc
tu l'exclu une première fois tu l'ex une
deuxième fois qu'est ce que jean-michel
le blanc caire a fait il a changé les
règles
comment il fallait l'accord des parents
pour pouvoir enlever l'enfant de
l'établissement et dire ben en fait non
non tu t'es juste un élément beaucoup
trop perturbant pour la classe et donc
du coup tu aller dans une autre classe
avec des enseignants peut-être des ans
des médiateurs des classes plus strictes
différentes salles des classes relais on
appelle ça comme ça et avoir fallait
l'accord les parents donc si les parents
me disent non si les parents ils sont
ils sont pas dans l'engagement de la
responsabilité des parents viennent
râler en plus derrière pour dire mais
pourquoi que j'ai fait ça à mon fils
finalement il lui trouve des excuses la
responsabilité de tous un qu'on puisse
l'exclure et qu'on l'emmène dans une
autre classe sans l'accord des parents
ça c'est jean-michel face et jean michel
blanckaert méthyle éducationnel en mai
ces jeunes chez son père
c'est jean-michel
tutelle et
de l'autre côté il faut il faut
embarquer les paroisses à leurs
responsables ça boit ça s'est fait à
noter le nom mais c'est bon
mais justement non mais non ces
nouvelles règles ouais ça c'est jean
michel blanquer et c'est depuis 2009
c'est bien alors oui c'est tout récent
mais est ce qu est ce que vous le
ressentez ça sur le terrain non on ne le
ressentent on ne le ressent pas vous
voulez ce qui me choque c'est si cette
scène n'avait pas été filmée peut-être
que personne n'en aurait parlé à ce que
dit bernadette que finalement les élèves
auraient été mais n'aurait même pas été
sanctionné aurait une petite sanction
c'est ça qui est qu'elle est misérable
finalement on est obligé de jeter en
pâture cette vidéo sur la place publique
finalement pour sanctionner les
responsables et surtout pour penser à la
victime c'est ça qui est incroyable et
moi j'entends madame la ministre nous
dire en effet enfin la secrétaire d'état
nous dire en effet que il existe des
structures particulières c'est des
structures relais mais la vérité c'est
quand il ya des conseils de discipline
beaucoup d'élèves ne vont pas dans ces
structures en fait ils tournent d'un
établissement à l'autre donc un élève
qui perturbe dans un établissement il
est viré au bout de deux trois mois il
refait exactement la même chose dans un
autre établissement moi que je crois
qu'il faut de l'autorité il faut créer
des formes d'internât qui permettent en
effet de remettre dans le droit chemin
ses adolescents parce que quand on est
adolescent on n'est pas perdu il ya
quelque chose à faire il faut que nous
et éducation nationale on sache
finalement remettre ces gens dont le
chemin de la république dont le chemin
du vivre ensemble pour que véritablement
notre rôle puisse aller jusqu'à son père
est là j'étais un tout petit point est
ce que c'est important que sur
l'histoire la vidéo ce qui s'est passé
c'est à midi il ya eu il ya eu la
violence immédiatement la professeur a
été a été reçue par le proviseur et la
plainte a été lancé le même jour comment
elle va la prendre avant mais écoutez
moi de ce que j'en sais pas ce que j'ai
eus que le les échanges avec le recteur
1 le soutien juridique il est lancée
sous la protection de fonctionnel pour
qu'elle n'ait pas de problèmes d'argent
ou des deux d'avocats on le fait 2 il ya
un soutien psychologique immédiatement
et 3 qu'est-ce-qui trois départs et
trois skis hyper important c'est qu'à
une solidarité dans l'établissement et
ça ça compte alors ce que quand tu es
tout seul et que tu vis ça et que
derrière ta pâte et collecte a pas loin
sur vraiment les les autres qui te
disent maintenant et enfin c'est pas
normal village il avait juste pas à
faire ça et le premier qui essaie
d'expliquer ou de justifier cesser enfin
cette réaction et c'est cet axe hyper
grave est idiot et il faut piégeage et
qu'est ce qu'il a dit l'élève qui a fait
ce qu'on a pu le lui par l'iace qu'est
ce qu'il a dit moi je mangeais pas se
passer pour lui la peau ce qui va se
passer pour lui c'est que là il ya un
conseil de discipline qui est convoqué
comme il ya eu des cas antérieurs il
sera potentiellement mais ça sera la
décision du conseil de discipline et
exclus ya une procédure judiciaire qui
est quand même lancé parce qu'il ya eu
deux plaintes c'est pas anodin et puis
évidemment les parents sont convoqués et
fo moi je suis moi panther vous le
disait le professeur hafsi faut pas
qu'on met tout sur le dos de l'éducation
nationale je suis d'accord avec vous
mais à un moment il a des parents ce
garçon il a des parents et si on veut un
moment responsablité chacun sait que lui
ces actes graves il faut qu'ils soient
sanctionnés parce que si on ne comprend
pas que c'est grave de celui qui a filmé
soit sanctionné trois ses parents parce
qu'ils sont quand même sens et
l'accompagné l'éduquer et 4 tous les
acteurs de l'autorité autour de lui les
assauts mais moi je bosse beaucoup avec
les assauts que je pense je pense que le
sport permet aussi d'accompagner
l'éducation c'est tout le monde de
l'éducation populaire c'est un moment
dans ta vie on te dira le président doit
jouer au foot jeudi
le président va jouer au foot je vous
avais plus d'infos direct cyril comme
avec le variétés club a joué au foot
possédant pour promouvoir le foot et le
sport permet le sport permet de
s'émanciper et l'espoir et permet plein
plein de transmission de valeurs ça
c'est juste inacceptables il faut que
tous les adultes autour le condamne quoi
est ce que les professeurs sont en
danger c'est là c'est la question qu'on
compose raymond et qui dit on va vous
entendrez bon ben moi je pense que oui
ils sont de plus en plus vous êtes tous
les we c'est rare mais quand on voit ces
images a d'abord avec de la chance cette
dame que la tête ne tape pas quelques
intérim et lui le calcul pas ça quand il
fait ça c'est une connerie qu'il a fait
est bien évidemment qui sans danger est
bien évidemment qu'il faut les aider
j'entends le monsieur qui dit il faut
des internats j'entends le mot
adolescence et moi je vous rejoins c'est
vrai mais à un moment donné il faut
responsabiliser les parents mais pas
contre le gamin il a 15 16 ans avant moi
à 15 16 ans j'étais foutu je vie des
zeks des extincteurs au collège j'étais
travailler à 15 ans j'étais mort à 15 c
au cp ce1 cm1 c'est là qu'il faut déjà
dire aux enfants ont fait pas et aux
parents on ne fait pas n'importe quoi
avec l'école de la république on viens
pour apprendre les seuls gens qui
peuvent sauver ces mecs là excès des
profs personnes les aides ni dans le
quartier sont pas aidés ni leurs parents
ils sont pas aidés parce que leurs
parents ils ont aussi des problèmes les
seuls gens qui peuvent te donner du
savoir est mon plus gros regret de ma
vie c'est d'avoir insulté des profs
c'est d'avoir craché dans une classe et
d'avoir vidé des extincteurs dans le sas
aujourd'hui à 45 ans c'est mon plus gros
regret aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut faire
c'est donner les moyens aux profs en cp
en c1 quand même limite maternelle les
parents qui abandonnent déjà leurs
enfants en cp c'est trop tard il a 15
ans il a quel âge sur la vidéo il a 15
ans tu vas à l'esprit qu'il faut aller
dans un internat il est foutu lui c'est
la jeune association qui met entre
guillemets ne prenait pas au pied de la
lettre c'est très drôle en fait que
c'est trop tard me pour lui dire ce que
tu as fait c'est pas bien et s'en fout
il s'en fout il a claqué la porte il
s'en fout c'est pas son premier truc qui
fait il s'est pas levé un matin pour
claquer la porte d'une d'une prof ça
fait déjà longtemps qu'ils en aient
schalit pas d'aujourd'hui moi je pense
pas que les professeurs soient en danger
plus qu'avant moi le problème c'est
qu'on le voit plus qu'avant mais ils ne
sont pas en danger puisque avant c'était
réseaux sociaux mettent en avant des
violences j'avais une professeur de
dessin qui était à genoux et à la
fenêtre h femme en train d'essayer de
sauter mais ça on le voyait pas parce
qu'on n'avait pas c'est foutu réseaux
sociaux en fait il est là le problème
pour moi ces jeunes même ceux qui sont
accros aux réseaux et ils veulent
toujours plus de followers et ils
veulent toujours plus montré d'europe
ils ont été alpagués par cette histoire
de réseaux sociaux ils deviennent tous
et d'un gilet jaune ils sont plus dans
ce
monde est alors moment donné ils veulent
toujours avoir la pas du faux loire l'a
pas du truc et un moment donné où on
s'en sort plus dans cette histoire de
réseaux sociaux et 7 cette histoire de
gens anonymes sur les réseaux et
bailleur a toujours des problèmes parce
que finalement il ya des méchants et
bien ça va tomber l'action les
mais pour moi c'est le fond du débat
parce qu'il ya 15 ans ça dépend dans les
collèges dans lesquelles vous étiez
meilleur moyen à 15 ans j'étais dans des
collèges et des lycées où il se passait
des choses comme ça et on n'en parlait
pas c'est tout mathieu mais moi
j'aimerais poser une question à madame
la ministre enfin je ramène à ça quand
j'étais plus jeune moi quand j'étais
plus jeune moi il y avait ce qu'on
appelait des pions moi j'étais en
internat il y avait des pions qui
étaient des mecs qui ressemble un peu à
mokhtar pardon et on a un nom je suis
désolé t'as pas envie de laisser la main
c'est un bon piont
des surveillants et t'as pas envie de
rentrer quand à 15 c
il aimait à leicester vont faire
respecter l'autorité et du coup les
balles les professeurs étaient été
dévoilée a été défendu par ses percées
par ces purs là et nouba pardon bas
comment étaient des gamins quand on voit
plus forts reculs être est ce en quoi
est ce que dans saisissez-la n'ya pas
avec tout chômage qui est pourquoi est
ce qu'il n'ya pas des gens qui s'aiment
c'est par monsieur que j'aime beaucoup
mais qui a dû faire sur ce mot qui va
qui a faim de krav maga demain pourquoi
n'y a pas des gens pour pour simplement
les défendre et pour faire en sorte que
ces gamins de 15 ans vous n'avez pas
compris que les gares desservies
aujourd'hui ils vont attendre le
mobile
alabama et bien que ça je pense que
c'est oui oui là aussi la région il ya
des morts des médiateurs et ailleurs
mais c'est pas mais le sujet c'est pas
c'est pas la taille ou la force clôture
quand on en arrive là c'est que c'est
déjà trop grave par contre je là je vous
rejoins sur le cpc 20 premiers première
mission et c'est pas une punchline
premier truc que j'aime chez blanquart
fait c'est apprendre à lire écrire
compter respecter autrui c'est pas nos
dents et ça ça commence au cp au cm2 se
sont tus commencent à détruire à griffer
machin à mettre des tenues dans les
détails dans les toilettes quand tu
respectes pas ton coton camarades c'est
une sorte d'engrenage en fait tu te
respecte plus toi mais tu rend invivable
climat et face à ça tout le monde le
début a souri un petit bug oui oui
d'accord lire écrire compter à respecter
autrui sauf que ça commence en
dédoublant les classes de cp et ce1 donc
dans les tous les hommes les endroits où
c'est le plus dur parce que parfois tu
as les parents qui sont non pas qu'ils
sont pas assez là qu'ils peuvent pas ta
compagnie et finalement tu laisse pas
filer la thune laissera filer la bri
faut la garder assez brillant et dans la
foulée tu fais quoi ceux qui ont
vraiment envie de s'en sortir tu l'aimés
dans des internats d'excellence tulle et
valorise tout leur donne les moyens de
s'en sortir vraiment parce que oui on en
a besoin et oui c'est l'école qui est
lancé
je j'aimerais vous croire ça fait 20 ans
qu'on nous dise et revient ce les
internats d'excellence sont les classes
qu'on va dédoubler pour né pas 45
enfants dans une classe parce que ça va
être très compliqué et c'est moi je peux
moi il ya quelque chose qui m'a
interpellé lorsque le recteur a écrit le
texte après il a quoi sa bio pour les
gens qui nous rejoignent impôts locaux
cette vidéo si vous nous rejoignez un
taux ramené vous regardez cette vidéo
qui fait énormément parler voilà très
très violente qu'est ce qu'il dit sur
cette vidéo voilà
la carrière de l'acteur qu'est ce que
dit le recteur il condamne cet acte
isolé
donc moi déjà ça m'a fait tiquer c'est
une fois encore on lâche on lâche les
professeurs en leur disant vous savez
quoi pas de bol vous êtes tombés sur un
sur un môme qui était un peu d un peu
difficile mais c'est un acte isolé votre
hiérarchie est en fait moi j'ai le
sentiment que la hiérarchie elle met
sous le tapis quand c'est quand ça
devient un peu emmerdant et en disant ce
n'est qu'un acte isolé c'est pas c'est
pas un souci globale et donc on fait on
fait semblant de dire comme c'est un
phénomène qu'on a sur les convois on
peut pas le mettre sous le tapis mais le
reste voilà
les entrées en fait bien il ya un truc
ça c'est vrai ça c'était vrai avant
pourquoi parce que l'établissement
voulait pas qu'on dise chez moi c'est
pas beau il se trouve que c'était dhabi
semences c'est plutôt un bon climat et
donc du coup ils l'expriment je pense de
manière sincère mais quand on arrive et
quand on dit en fait faut arrêter avec
le pas de vagues parce que c'est ça le
truc c'est que plus on établissement a
une réputation - bonne - t'as envie plus
les parents qui ont les moyens de sortir
leurs enfants de ces établissements les
met pas dedans et finalement tu passes
dans un engrenage mais qui emmène ne
qu'au pire parce que plus personne ne se
croisent pas de vagues c'est quoi c'est
chaque messac micro acte chaque acte de
violences et déclaré dans un outil c'est
au petit s'appelle fait établissements
alors c'est un peu c'est un non vulgaire
enfin l'établissement jusqu'à sous la
selle mais ça s'appelle comme ça fut
établissements chaque vague c'est le
message qui est donné à l'ensemble des
recteurs en leur disant vous ne mettez
plus sous le tapis oui pendant des
années ça a été ça c'est vrai enfin les
professeurs comme si on a entendu qui
ont témoigné disait moi j'ai été alerté
ma hiérarchie et on m'a dit pas de
vagues et c'est vrai ça a été ça pendant
extrêmement l'entente pendant des
dizaines d'années et depuis l'arrivée
pour le coup devant michel ça a été
l'opposition a été le changement par
contre il faut changer les mentalités
parce que pour certains il faut qu'ils
croient que c'est vrai enfin sans renier
et c'est pour ça que dès le moment que
ya eu cette action n'a pas cet acte i
père violent 1 on dépose plainte et
l'établissement dépôt de plainte est
situé c'est vraiment été dans le pas de
vague aurait pas eu dépôt de plainte
vous allez bye l'accompagnement et les
ans à venir vous allez suivre 7,7 cette
enseignante qui revient extrêmement
choquée ouais il faut enfin un
accompagnement psychologique alors ce
n'est pas l'adversaire mais elle va pas
reprendre le travail tout de suite elle
peut pas reprendre je pense qu'il faut
vraiment notre panier en psychologie
tracer ses violons pour elle si l'élan
pour les salaires dans la suite aussi
est-ce que vous avez pas peur qu'elle ne
veuille plus haut pas là du tout c'est
ça c'est franchement c'est pour le coût
réel et les professionnels moi je qui va
j'ai pas envie quitter la maison pensez
vous qu'est ce que pensait qu'elle doit
reprendre tout de suite le travail je
pense que c'est de répondre à la
question mais c'est un véritable
traumatisme
vous savez syrie quand on s'engage dans
l'enseignement c'est parce qu'on a c'est
une passion c'est une vocation à la base
et c'est vrai que nous convient en
classe on n'est pas là pour se faire
insulter on n'est pas là pour se taire
mais méprisé sûr on est là pour
transmettre un savoir mais il ya quelque
chose de plus profond dans l'éducation
nationale c'est une forme de culture
c'est une forme d'idéologie finalement
qui victimise les coupables et qui
culpabilise les victimes et c'est vrai
que ça c'est toujours cette culture de
l'excusé qui n'est pas acceptable et je
suis d'accord c'est vrai que depuis
qu'elle jean michel blanquer c'est un
petit peu changé
jean michel benquet raté quelque chose
d'extraordinaire il a mis un coup de
pied dans la fourmilière notamment pour
dire que cette idéologie 68 table il n'y
en avait marre ce que disait alors
randonnée il faut de l'autorité et il
faut tout simplement renouer avec
l'école de la république moi j'en sais
ambiance assurée on sait que des mots
alors ces démos évident ac se sont
évidemment mais on commence en avoir un
petit peu la couleur notamment sur la
lutte contre le communautarisme ou sur
l'islamisme and on peut signaler de
manière beaucoup plus rouge ça bouge un
tout petit peu mais tant qu'on en
viendra le temps qu'on viendra pas à
bout de cette idéologie de cette culture
de l'excusé qui est partagé par un bon
nombre de professeurs on ne s'en sortira
jamais c'est idéologiquement qu'il faut
en effet dégraisser le mammouth merci
aux parents dégraisser le mammouth pouf
derrière de bouillir
fait toujours des petits pains il est en
duplex
[Rires]
je suis réflexe depuis un pays où on
arrête de se voiler la face donc si vous
voyez je suis pas avec vous d'accord ce
soir parce qu'ils ont entendu le salaire
des gens appartient même pardon je vous
connais pas décidément je connais
personne ce soir
c'est incroyable c'est absolument
incroyable ce que j'entends qu'est ce
qu'un projet en tant que le sport ça
aide les enfants et c'est important pour
l'intégration c'est pour ça qu'on colle
dépasse sanitaires pour le sport c'est
pas grave
voyez le problème c'est qu'ils
s'appellent de la realpolitik
c'est un mot effectivement qui vous
échappe essai de la realpolitik parce
que aller précisément dans ce que vous
nommez les quartiers aller voir les
éducateurs ce qu'il advient excusez moi
madame but non je te venise et son livre
envie de france effectivement pour le
coup la vérité c'est que aujourd'hui il
ya deux problèmes c'est que à la notion
d'autorité mais on doit concéder alors
jean michel blanquer at il fait mieux
que les autres ça c'est discutable ou
bien quelquefois palais présidentiel on
vous dira le contraire la vérité c'est
qu'à un moment donné en fait vous avez
aucun plan vous n'avez aucune idée de là
où vous allez et pour une raison très
simple en fait parce que c'est ce que
disait monsieur c'est à dire que depuis
des années on a décidé de victimiser les
coupables depuis des années on a décidé
qu effectivement il fallait que tout le
monde ait sa chance que tout le monde
aille jusqu'au bac koné l'apprentissage
alain a porté à treize ans est un vrai
problème que ensuite effectivement et en
amont les primaires les maternelles la
vérité elle est relativement simple
c'est très simple en fait c'est que vous
n'avez pas de programme autre fait que
de la politique plutôt
merci tard allait dire oui on à moi je
manque c'est en un mot c'est totalement
faux ainsi on à nous de nous on a on est
passé à plus de 580 1000 contrats
d'apprentissage parce que pour nous
c'est une voie d'excellence d'euros des
revenus à des fondamentaux il ya le plan
il est très clair il faut lire écrire
savoir comptait revenir sur des essences
à vous a dit loew et lever les tabous
j'ai été à l'école m'a bien le plan des
mois très simple la ccip dollars je suis
désolé monsieur mais sur ce coup là pour
le coup jean michel blanquer recommencer
du début à la fin ce mandat ne l'aura
pas bonne on voulait qu'il a été agressé
en plein de classe les professeurs sont
ils en danger oui à 85% non à 14 par
l'un de ces essais c'est incroyable